being a gp is a bit like being a [ __ ]
hairdresser you have to go in and you
have to figure out how to make people's
lives better but the major factor with
that
statement is that that doesn't mean
anything
unless the patient is motivated to
change if the patient comes in and you
say you need to do x
y and z to make this condition better
and they don't that's on them
and that's the truth i can do all i can
but if they have the mental capacity
to say i get if i don't do these
treatments i might come to serious harm
or death and they decide not to
there is nothing i can do about that
this is a first where i'm actually
recording with a guest
who i don't know who it is so what
should i call you mr gp doc
no i think why don't you why don't you
call me max i think that's uh
i think that's a good starting point
cool so max which is the
pseudonym moniker which you've used to
write this book
so why are you anonymous yeah that's
right so
so the um so i guess my full anonymized
name is uh dr max skittle
and max to to everyone including my
patients
um why anonymous well i think there's a
couple of reasons the first is
is to protect my patients i mean the
whole when you decide to write something
like a
a waltz and all book a medical biography
um or sort of um talking about your your
life in the job
you um you need to protect the
confidentiality of your patients
and and that's not just anonymizing them
and changing
ages and genders and ethnicities but
it's also about
um i guess protecting yourself so by me
being anonymous
it gives another layer of protection to
my patients and it
it probably stops me from getting fired
as well
so so it's kind of a win-win yeah
but i get that well sadly we've broken
at least one of the potential
um fibs that you had which was that you
could have been maxine
in real life um so that one's out there
i may just have a very deep voice you
have no idea imagine or if you're using
a really fancy voice modulator that
would have been exactly that would have
been you never know
so you never know why did you decide to
write this book
uh it's a good question i mean i think
there's probably
the simple answer is that i love talking
about health and i love writing
and uh and i think that the opportunity
came up when i kept coming home and i
was like oh that's just such a good
experience or
such a haunting experience or such a
hilarious experience
and the emotions that it made me feel on
that day
i just thought you know what why can't
we put this down on paper
and why can't we share it with people
and
and let them see what the job's like and
let them see
um you know life's journey through the
eyes of uh
multiple patients and you might find
that
some of them resonate with you you might
see a journey of a patient that i've
written about
and gone yeah that was me or it might be
that that's you in the future like you
have no idea
um and that's the sort of thing that
led me to write the book it's kind of
semi autobiographical
diaries format isn't it kind of goes
through day by day over a
tight period yeah that's right it's a
it's a diary um
uh version of a year in my life
and uh it sort of takes you through the
journey of my day-to-day patients but
also gives you an understanding about
um what happens behind the scenes like
how does a
how does a gp surgery run what are the
highs and lows what the hiccups
um and then i suppose there's a sub
context to that
it's about my life and about my
young family and i guess how that
blurring of the work-life balance
um occurs and how it impacted in me and
then
because that's something i guess that we
all experience we're desperate to try
and keep our work and our life separate
to a degree
but with technology and just the
emotions that work pulls out people now
you realize that that's not possible and
in the book
um there are definitely times when when
that comes through
would you say that you're a typical
representation of a gp are you
a fairly representative gpa is your
experience going to be sort of
synonymous with many others yeah i mean
i i don't think that um
i don't think that um gps
experience are necessarily a different
caseload i mean we all see the same
people walking through the doors
it varies a little bit because what
happens is people decide
who they want to see and so you start to
get a bit of a
a niche so for example i knew that i
loved seeing
um children uh because it allows you to
be a kid for 10 minutes
but also sort of um adolescents and
and teenagers who i guess prefer someone
who
yeah i mean let's be blunt i'm not near
to their age but nearer to their age
than say
a fifty or six year old gp and um and
he's fairly straight talking and and
you know that's something that that i've
always tried to do
you know i don't beat around the bush i
think you need to be honest with people
and um and that's never more the case
than with your patients in front of you
yeah the topic of work-life balance
really interested me that i i had a
question down here that just asked our
gp's normal people
but upon reading the book it comes
across that you are but there's
something
weird and everyone that's listening
might feel the same or this might just
be some bizarre quirk of my own
mentality but yeah you kind of see
gps doctors as these like weird
angelic omnipotent sort of fountains of
life's givingness
you almost don't expect them to have a
life outside of that it sounds bizarre
like
you know i expect a bus driver to be
gruff to me if he's had a bad day but i
don't expect my gp to do that
does that make sense it does kind of
believe that they're almost above the
the decree the law of normal normal
behavior
yeah i mean i i think i i wasn't sure if
i could swear on this chris
to be blunt i mean it's [ __ ] i mean
we're all
we're all human and uh gp's more so than
ever
um we the i
the concept of emotion um is a really
difficult one with the gp and i think it
varies throughout your career because
basically you have to learn to to really
um suppress it when you're in front of a
patient because
you've probably read the book you know
there are there are patients that
make me you know see red
they're ones that make you want to cry
there are ones that maybe want to bang
the desk
shout at them just be like what the hell
are you doing
but you had to try and compose that to a
degree and then
tell them in a steady tone
that i think they're crazy that i think
they're mad for making that decision
that i think they're
you know they're talking [ __ ] and i'm
gonna give them the truth
and that that's the reality and that we
need to find some way of
of marrying the patient agenda with the
with the
with my gp agenda because my agenda is
always to try and do the best for that
patient
but the challenge is that they don't
always see it that way and that's that's
part of the beauty of the job but
there's a veneer to being a gp and
what happens i mean it happened in the
book secret gp
that veneer gets scratched away at
points because you know when you've been
slammed by
you know the 15th super complex unhappy
patient
10 minutes after 10 minutes like you
just want to explode
and um and there are times when
when i when i feel like actually i've
had a day like that today where you know
i've literally come home and i i've just
i want to sit down and have a beer and
just decompress
because it's been it's been one of those
days and um
yeah i mean you try and mask it as much
as you can but actually i think
conversely patients want to see you as a
person
you know you're not as you said this
sort of like you're not a deity
you're nothing like that you are a human
who has learnt a job
and you're trying to help the person in
front of you and
it's not about being nice to them it's
about being honest
and telling them the truth and helping
them through processes
um related to their health and um you
can have
you have a nice [ __ ] gp if you want but
that's not what i want to be
that's a good way to put it here how
much time per month do you think that
you spend with your finger inside of
bums
total on average um
oh that's a good question actually i
mean it you know i don't hang around
when i'm up there
let's be honest so okay let's work it
out so what's your what's typical rectal
exam length
20 seconds yeah because you've got it
you've got to essentially
get them on their side laying on their
sort of fetal position
knees up i usually sort of say think of
queen of country
uh you got a lubed uh uh gelled glove
yep into into gluteal cleft yeah
absolutely you weren't expecting me to
know that were you dr skittle
that's yeah one of my best friends my
best friends is also a doctor as well so
i fantastic so you know you know what to
ask me now
and um you excellent you examine the
outside and then you say okay bit of
pressure and then you go and you sweep
around feeling for masses
and you sweep around feeling the
prostate or the edge of the prostate and
then you come out look at the glove
you're looking for blood you're looking
for
um mucus um
and then you go away and give them a
tissue and not to wipe their eye that is
that's to
sort the other end or two tissues
sometimes there yeah you know and that
and that's it but yeah i mean i probably
got enough
i probably had my finger up for long
enough to to see a good ad break
in a month okay cool yeah well i mean
it's it's all just accumul it's all just
accumulating time
you know i had um i had salmonella
a couple of years ago from africa yeah
really would not recommend it
yeah um yeah i got a call
that wasn't a finger up the bum scenario
no you don't need wrong for that
shame no um but um there you are they're
mate there are paid services everywhere
i'm sure you can find it
i just need to get a really good friend
uh exactly
i got a call here's an interesting one
for you i didn't even think of this
i got a call from environmental health
asking where i'd been eating recently
because they knew that i had salmonella
before i got a call from my doctor's
surgery telling me that the diagnosis
was salmonella
yeah it's pretty um pretty swift isn't
it so public health england will have
notifiable diseases
if some salmonella comes up they need to
find where the source is and track it
down
and uh isolate it if need be i mean you
know you know
it's a very different game when we think
about the coronavirus pandemic but
it's that on steroids really isn't it
yeah i was like
um oh i'm gonna guess that's my
diagnosis thank you for telling me and
just obviously some fella
some girl on the other end of the phone
trying to track down like a a
hotel that had been serving bad chicken
or something unless yeah unless you fly
to africa
that's that's not going to happen yeah
how hard is it
to get fired as a gp
uh well i haven't been fired yet but i'm
probably working quite hard to um
i think i think it's pretty hard
you know gps are in demand you know
we're we're short thousands of gps and
and
government after government make pledges
that they're going to uh you know boost
you know the gp numbers by five thousand
come 2020 2021
and it just doesn't quite get there i
think to get to get struck off
to get fired as a gp i think you have to
have gross misconduct and then
uh you know they're the kind of guys and
girls that you're seeing in the daily
mail
um after their sort of lawsuit so you're
seeing people that are sort of using
sexual exploitation taking photographs
unnecessary examinations um
you don't you wouldn't get struck off
for just being a bad gp you get pulled
aside
mentored trained up i mean the training
is good
um the reason you get uh
you'd probably get fired if you've got a
darker side to you that comes out
oh yeah i was thinking that the stakes
are obviously quite high
there's a story in the book about a lady
who comes through and
points a finger at you and accuses you
of not detecting her
husband's soon-to-onset heart attack
that kills him
and he's like well that's that
obviously there's a lot of
emotion and not culpability but you
there's there's a
um a potential for someone to find you
create you be the the reason the behest
of this particular problem that's
occurred right
and and that and to be honest with you
chris that that happens a lot
partly because we're the person sat in
front of them you know if you're looking
for someone to blame
for for for a loved one's death
um a gp is someone who's there is
accessible
and and often i i think i remember i
said about this in the book with that
particular
um lady you know it's a grief reaction
and i
bear no bear no bad feelings towards her
because while it was a horrible
experience for me
her experience was was immeasurably
worse
and what i was receiving from her was
her grief reaction
um you know and and i suppose that's you
get a thick skin
as a gp as a doctor in general i think
or as a nurse or any healthcare
professional
you get a thick skin because that stuff
happens all the time
you get blamed for missing cancers you
get blamed for
not diagnosing heart attacks or not
seeing the signs of one
you know we are human and um i will miss
things in my career
i will miss cancers i know that because
i'm i'm not you know i'm not infallible
and i'm human
and it's just that's the life that we
live and
um every doctor knows that if you speak
to a doctor who says i'm never gonna
miss a cancer i'm never gonna miss a an
acute
serious illness that could lead to a
fatality
i think they're killing themselves i
mean that you know we have to have the
humility to say
i'm gonna i'm really gonna [ __ ] up at
some point and i'm going to have to just
shoulder that
because if you're seeing at all times
yeah
and if you're seeing hundreds of
patients a week you just need to miss
one thing
like just one tiny thing one subtle
symptom
that's uh you know stakes are high max
the stakes are really
but that's why i love the job i mean i
love the i love the risk that comes with
it people
you know when i when i suddenly realized
i was coming out medical school and
going into being a gp i was like oh my
god this is gonna be the most boring
experience of my life
but you know i've done a e i've survived
all that i've enjoyed it it's great fun
but i want to come home on the weekends
i want to come home to my family in the
evenings
um let's make that decision what i found
is that every day is just the cacophony
of of experiences of um
with patients and i i love it like from
the acute illnesses to the utterly
weird and wonderful to the um
sad and somber i mean you know you can
one day you can be talking about someone
saw me and within 10 minutes you're
talking to
you know the guy in the book benny who
came comes in and his question is
you know seriously max what what's the
meaning of life
and that that puts him immediately
on my top five patient list of all time
because just to have the to have the the
guts to come in and ask the question
that perhaps we all do wonder from time
to time particularly at sort of 2 a.m
when you can't sleep
to come in and ask me and think that i'm
going to have the answer yeah it's a
it's a low-key
compliment man really really is i know
who's going to have the answer to this
dr skittle dr skittle knows the answer
to this one
exactly and uh and you know well you had
to read the book to find out what
happens but uh
he is uh he's one of my all-time
favorites never forget him no
it's a little bit like being a doctor
being a gp sounds a little bit like
being a really hardcore hairdresser
like everyone that comes in their hair's
[ __ ]
like it's totally [ __ ] and the best that
you can do is get them to leave with an
acceptable hairdo which might happen in
three weeks time
yeah yeah well you know what i've got
having like you and like all of us just
gone through the lockdown and had a
locked down haircut
and tried to cut my wife's hair
it is not that easy and so hat first of
all
let's just give her hats off to the
hairdressers because it is not easy
um but yeah i mean being a gp is a bit
like being a [ __ ] hairdresser uh you do
you have to
you have to go in and you have to figure
out how to make people's lives better
but but the the major factor with that
statement is that that doesn't mean
anything unless the patient is motivated
to change
if the patient comes in and you say you
need to do x y and z to make this
condition better
and they don't that's on them that's not
that and that's the truth um i can do
all i can to try and encourage them make
them see and understand
why they need to do something but if
they have the mental capacity
to say i get if i don't do these
treatments
i might come to serious harm or death
and they decide not to
there is nothing i can do about that
that really surprised me to find that
out yeah
a doctor tells me to do a thing and i'm
i'm
pretty much to the letter but you had a
lady
who had put off a breast cancer
assessment for
four times because of work you had a guy
who was like pre-diabetic high blood
cholesterol smoked every day drank every
day didn't eat anything was also like
looked like he might be a low-key 60
year old porn star and then
yeah mr tosca he is one of my faves he
was like just came in smelling of sort
of stale cigar and sex
he was uh he was he was a great he was a
great guy
uh i hope he's still with us like all
these people and they're not
you know saying look this is this is
where you're at and there was another
lady who had an existential crisis
in front of you and didn't bother to go
to her her
cancer treatment or whatever because she
was like yeah give it to someone that
deserves it
and i'm thinking like yeah just seeing
people like that it must be it must be
challenging as a
as a doctor to do the thing get them to
this as much as you can do
lead a horse to water but yeah then you
get stuck it is uh and some people find
that harder than others so
for me i i i i'm very you know i'm
i'm blunt i will say that you know if
you don't do this
this is what could happen and
um and of course you do i don't want
people to think that's me being
incredibly harsh and then going that's
it i've wiped my hands with them so the
lady for example who you mentioned
who and then it was a cancer treatment
it was her her diabetes appointment and
and
um she'd said i like you know i i'm not
good enough to have
treatment give it to someone else who's
who's salvageable
and um and and in the book i think i
said you know i will follow up with her
in a few weeks time
and i will say oi have you changed your
mind
and here's why you should change your
mind again and you keep doing that so
i guess i guess what i'm saying is
people may listen to me or they may read
the book which
i'm getting a feeling is going to be a
bit of a marmite book with people
um they might think
max is a real dick but actually every
single decision i make everything i say
or do
is is in the patient's interests
because that's why i love the job
because i'm doing something to help try
and help someone else
you just don't need to sugarcoat this
stuff because
health doesn't is sugar coated enough
you know you just sort of need to go on
sort of instagram and and you know you
can get some shiny enameled tooth
and doctor who can tell you this stuff
um but
but the reality is that
you know you have to be blunt you have
to be harsh um
because you're trying to do everything
in their best interest
the rubber really really does meet the
road when you go and
sit down with the gp i don't want the
guy on instagram
who who did a level three nvq
in physiotherapy i don't want him i want
someone that had to go through the fire
and brimstone that is five years of
med school and two years of locum and
blah blah blah blah blah
and you experienced that and and in the
secret gp i i have a couple of
flashbacks to
you know there's a chapter about when i
went through my
gp training and what led me to to make
that decision and there are stories in
there about
you know the experiences that you go
through as a junior doctor
and how you cut your teeth and as you
say how the rubber eats and
it meets the road can we play gp bingo
can you try and come up with some of the
cliche phrases
that you either find yourself saying a
lot or that you hear your other doctors
saying a lot
so for instance on this show i'll tend
to say something like
the rubber meets the road or the tip of
the spear or you
where you gotta have a pair of brass
balls for that what are some of the ones
that you find yourself saying a lot
so so i i think for me
uh often it's what you want
[Laughter]
because actually sometimes you just need
to cut through all the faff
and just say to them what is it you want
um what do you think you've got
definitely what do you think you got
because
people will come in and listen to you
and they'll say actually well i you know
i played dr google and i think it's this
um that's the that's the doctor
equivalent of do you know why i pulled
you over
exactly exactly
um and then i suppose the other one is
well
so this is this is pr and i mentioned
this in the
epilogue as well this is the the
pre-coronavirus
um statement it's probably just a virus
okay and that is the most terrifying
thing isn't it
that for for a gp you come in you're
like oh i need antibiotics which treat
bacterial infections i've got
i've got a cough and i've got a sore
throat and runny nose i need antibiotics
and you go look it's just a virus
it's a cold go home spend time with your
family
hug them take paracetamol go to work
you'll be fine you don't need to stay
off work for this it's just a virus
i mean fast forward to 2020 and and it's
a totally different world
can you imagine if you'd written this
book from
mid-2020 until early 2021
uh yeah i mean it would be you know
never say never there might be another
one in the pipeline at some point but
um the corona gp yeah that's
that's what i want yeah i mean this is
uh yeah i mean it'd be a different book
i mean i'd be clad
head to toe in uh personal protective
equipment i'd be
two two meters away from everyone um and
i'd be on the phone all the time because
you know gp has gone from 80
face-to-face 20
phone call as a split to
you know what was at one point for many
months 100 face-to-face
uh sorry 100 telephone call and if
you've got any symptoms that suggest you
might have
um a coronavirus infection you go off to
a hot hub where you're met by
um specialist teams so
it's just a it's a totally different uh
game and then
but things are changing you know we you
know we have to stay positive and we
have to think that things
to a degree will return to a normal
semblance of a
nhs and the healthcare service that we
we know and love
um but you'll probably find that gps
might talk to you on the phone more
because we've realized how much we can
actually manage on the telephone
and that frees up time it means that we
can speak to more patients
um and address more issues um
than perhaps historically we could you
were saying
that sometimes a significant portion of
the 10-minute window you have
to deal with a patient is actually taken
up with them getting
up from the seat getting through
reception finding finding the room that
you're in
so take us through you press the button
and your ten minute timer starts when
you say
uh christopher williamson please come to
unit
five or whatever yeah yeah absolutely so
so
put it in some context when i was first
a doctor and first a gp
um i would read your notes chris for
about
10 minutes you know um and i'd be like i
know all about you
i'm going to call you in that and and
you press the buzzer because you think
that to have that information you're
some
in some way sort of for armed about
what's about to happen
which is just it's just total bollocks
because what happens is you come in and
you throw something out of left field
like what's the meaning of life
um and uh and so that's and that's so
that's one of the things so
what we do is we um
when i press that button i stand at the
door and i go look
i wait for them to come down hi it's max
come in
and and then you just wait for them to
start talking because everyone will have
a preset
um idea about what they want to say
so everyone has got a preset sort of you
know
opening few sentences about max this is
my problem
this is what i've um this is what i've
got
and you need to let them get that out
because if you don't you're basically
um stopping everything that's been
stored up inside from them and then you
listen to it and then you
ask some more questions and then by
about minute three
you've got a rough idea you should have
or certainly i i try to do have a rough
idea about
what you think they've got
and what you need to do so what's your
management plan so
what tests you need to do what treatment
are you going to give and what follow-up
are you going to have
and then the next seven minutes have
basically spent
making that dream become a reality and
getting them out the door
that minute tan because you know
if you let it just kind of waffle on and
drag on and let them sort of you know
give you war and peace
what happens is that you don't really
get to the meat of the issue
um then you find that you can't address
all their problems
um and then you find that then knocks on
to the rest of your clinic so
you have to um you have to be quite
brutal i sometimes will just stop people
in their tracks and be like just
just what like i said you know when we
were playing gp bingo
what's the problem what do you think you
got what do you want
because then you can make things happen
whereas if you get to 10 minutes and
they're still telling you about their
first symptom
you know you can either push them out
the door or you can listen but then you
basically make everyone else late for
their appointments
so you know you've got to be a little
bit bullish about it
it seems to me i've got a number of
friends
who work in healthcare and at the junior
doctors or
on locum or whatever it might be and
they
have said unanimously that the worst
sorts of patients that they get
are the ones who come in and don't have
a defined problem
i don't know whether this is people who
are hypochondriacs whether this is
people who are just lonely and want some
attention
do you often come across those yeah we
do and
um the the undefined problem is
sometimes
the most unnerving problem because
you know i've had experiences where
patients have come in and they've said
i just don't feel right and you're
absolutely right there is a
there is a large group of people that
are lonely that are isolated
that um that just want to see you to
have company and that really does happen
or there are those people that think
that they might have something they've
gone online they've googled or they have
a family member who's just been
diagnosed with a cancer
they come and see you and they they
don't want to say i think i've got
cancer max they just say you know i just
don't feel right
and you had to explore that and and
you sometimes hear particularly sort of
more junior doctors say oh he or she was
a really bad historian like they just
didn't tell me what
they didn't give me any information that
that's not true
like you're just not good at getting it
and you need to
you know it's your job you're the
detective your job is to say okay well
let's pick apart your life for a second
you know who's at home with you what's
your daily routine like
what's your appetite like what are you
eating bowels okay passing urine
sweating at night any weight loss
bruising at all like you just go through
and you start in your head to mentally
tick off this checklist
but then as you do that you then come to
the third category of the
i just don't feel quite right people and
they're the ones that have got something
serious going on
that this is just the first sign of a
niggling symptom
that then manifests itself and and you
know you do your
blood tests or you do your chest x-ray
and you reveal something else and
and that's why it's really important
it's important never to
to to ignore any patient um and it
always to listen to them
and and i think the one thing that keeps
me going is that
i've got diagnostic curiosity you know i
want to know
i'm curious sherlock holmes yeah yeah
and it and it's
and and when you do it that way you
don't miss
stuff um if you get blase um
that's when you do miss stuff and you
make mistakes hey we serve and then
they're the ones that suffer
we said on the show last year the
curiosity is the most important
personality trait of the 20th century
and it turns out
not only is that true for entrepreneurs
and podcasters but also maybe for
doctors as well
which is pretty cool yeah yeah
absolutely and uh
you get bored in a job like this you
know you're going to switch off
you're not going to think and uh yeah
then error is coming
um i love my job i wouldn't do anything
else um
uh i think it's i think it's brilliant
you know you get to see the kind of
light in the dark and all the shades of
growing between
life it must be
the the spectrum of people and
experiences that you're exposed to
must be a real shock to the system at
least initially
it is so so when i was uh so when i was
working in the sort of inner city
surgery that where the books
um set um you did you went you saw
people from
extreme affluence to extreme poverty to
different socio-economic backgrounds
different ethnic backgrounds with
different
cultural beliefs around health to um
all the way to gang members so you know
there are people that
would be your friends that you think i'd
go you know i'd go out for dinner with
them they're
to the people that you cross the road
actively to avoid
um you know it's like you know i when i
you know in the book i talked about i
was out with
you know my wife um alice and we were we
were walking
and she was like i want a lollipop and
i'm like okay fine you want a lollipop
all right
and then of course there's just a big
gang of of
kids sort of um who are just hovering
around the shop door
who just look like they want to kill me
and then um
i'm just thinking bloody hell like of
all the manly things i need to go and
get
is a lollipop so i so i go and you know
i pick a magnum because i think that's
the most
manly masculine ice cream i could
possibly get from the
shop and then on the way out like one of
the uh one of the kids goes
you know all right dr max
and it turns out it's one of my patients
and and but you just
so you just don't know you know you and
and it doesn't matter who they are
you help everyone and because everyone's
got a back story
no one ended up in that position
by choice no one wants to see their gp i
think that's the other thing to say
chris is
people don't unless you're lonely people
don't want to come and say i've got a
problem
like people want to be healthy it's just
inherent with us
in us um there's a very small one or two
people who
who do like to be unhealthy and and and
sort of be medicalized but i think
that's a story for another day but
you know the majority of people want to
be healthy so they don't want to see us
um and i think that's the other thing
that we need to bear in mind it's an
interesting dynamic isn't it for the
relationship
between there's there's very few things
that you have to go out of your way
like maybe that maybe the tax man you
know or maybe like the people that deal
with like environmental health if you've
got you you don't really want to go and
see the guy that cleans your drains out
but even yeah it's not
yeah i mean i mean there are there are
lots you know there are lots people
don't
you know we like to think people like
seeing us but actually
you know making the best of a bad
situation mate that's what you do yeah
yeah exactly i didn't know that doctors
had performance targets
how does that work so um so i think
what people might not realize is that gp
surgery is a
is a is essentially a business i mean it
makes its own profits
um and what happens is there's
um there's something called quality and
outcome frameworks which is quaff
which i really don't want to bore your
listeners with chris because
it really is for the insomniacs uh to
hear about this
but in a nutshell you get
um if you have you know 10 000 people
and a thousand of those have high blood
pressure if you can control 95
of those people's blood pressure to
within a certain target
you will get extra payment so basically
they're saying well done
you've kept their blood pressure in good
control which means they have reduced
risk of cardiovascular disease like
heart attack or strokes
um therefore we will reward you um
with uh a financial remuneration um
and the the concept is that by doing
that
we are setting all these health
indicators
that if we can meet those targets those
targets are linked to research that says
if you do this if you have this in this
person
they will be healthier and therefore
they will have less
morbidity i.e ill health and less
mortality i.e death
um the the issue i have with it
is that it's uh it's retrospective
it's going this guy has got high blood
pressure
brilliant right let's uh give him a
medication
check his kidney function blood test
once a year
tell him to exercise and reduce his salt
content
get the blood pressure down and tick
we've met our
our quaff indicator um our target
what should happen is they should say
we'll pay you
for the amount of people that you can
keep off of that high blood pressure
register
will pay you to say think prospectively
rather than retrospectively to think
prospectively and say
you as a practice do everything you can
to keep them
within a healthy body weight having a
healthy diet exercising
and naturally keeping their blood
pressure down
will reward that um
yeah i mean and it doesn't work like
that for every target
but there are lots of you know you know
but
lifestyle is you know the buds and sort
of buzzword of the the
you know the 20th century but it's
rooted in
in fact as well in science that if you
can do the basics really well
you don't need drugs and you don't need
interventions
it's interesting thinking about the
parallels
between um physios physiotherapy
and doctors because there's a perverse
incentive bizarrely with a physio
in that when they get a person better
they no longer get paid off that person
and it's kind of this quaff thing is
kind of somehow
working deriving its metrics of success
from that in a weird way yeah they are
but i think the one thing i would say is
that even with with any healthcare
professional whether it be
physiotherapists occupational therapists
speech and language or nursing staff
doctors um
there are always patients always always
you know the world keeps turning people
keep getting older people get
muscular skeletal problems that need
physiotherapy
uh you know it is uh it will never be
short of um supply
how if you were to coach everyone who's
listening
thousands of people are listening if you
could coach them through how to be
the perfect patient what would you tell
them to do what can we all do to make
your lives
easier and to also get better outcomes
ourselves as patients
okay all right this is a good one so um
let's go with top three
so top three number one turn up on time
okay but i appreciate there's probably
gonna be a lot of people shouting at me
and get being like yeah but max you're
never
on time anyway um so
i can see where that that sort of
layering lies the rock becomes
circulating
um two is if you're coming with
something like a rash on your thigh
two is dress appropriately so if you're
coming to me with a sore knee
don't come wearing knee-high boots and
skinny jeans
because it takes about 10 minutes for
you to get that stuff off so i can
actually look at your knee
yep um and
and thirdly i would say
don't save up your problems i think
that's a really important one so
uh i have a lot of people
that come to me and think that they're
doing me this enormous
uh service by going max either
i've saved up um my seven problems
because i just thought you know you want
to see other people around the you know
in the in the previous week so i still
want to take
so anyway here's my seven problems and
i'm dividing seven by
uh 10 minutes or 600 seconds which um
you know well you know which i can't
even do the math
um not long basically and um and you
can't do it
so i would say two
three a real push but i also
i suppose chris i'd i'd um sort of put a
little
um alert on that as well saying that i
guess it because people
sometimes say oh by the way i've just
got this little thing
and they think it's a little thing but i
in fact think it's a really big thing
and and you then have to um go through a
whole process so
really interestingly and i get the one i
get a lot
is um women might say i spoke to him
talk to them about a couple of different
issues and then they'll say oh boy just
as they're going i
just got this one thing i just got i had
this little sort of
lump sort of just near my breast
and immediately you know you think okay
well i can't i can't unhear that
um you're halfway out the door yeah and
it may it could be for many reasons it
might be they're anxious about bringing
it up and
you know it's like you know so you know
like a 15 year old going and trying
buying a
buy porn mag in a in a news agents and
they like buy about seven different
things before they kind of point at the
playboy and saying can i have that as
well
you know it's it's really difficult and
they but in any case i've heard it and
at that point you have to go will i have
to examine you or i would like to
examine you
if they if they give you permission and
um you need a chaperone so i need to go
um downstairs to the reception and get a
trained chaperone
from reception to stand and make sure
that everything is above board and
if that anything ever did come to light
or be an issue we had a third
independent party
um and then you examine them and then
you then you make decision that is
that you can't do that in in a minute um
so i often will navigate that third tip
by going
okay um if they say i've got four things
i'll say
just just i don't want you guys to
detail but just give me the give me the
highlights give me the top four bullet
points
knee pain lump in the breast um
uh um constipation and i've got sore
right and i'll go okay tell me about the
breast lung first you organize them in
yeah yeah
priority yeah yeah you tree arch them
you triage them
because they might not why should they
know that one is more important the
other
you know that's my job uh and so
you know sometimes you have to be
blunter with others
uh um than some but you know that's
you know you try and again it's all
about trying to get as much
maximizing the time what you can give to
that patient
um and not getting annoyed at the same
time i think um
i think not saving it up is is a really
really good point we were talking on
this podcast on the pilot episode like
three years ago
about one of the uh regular co-hosts
yusuf
who uh had a uh i'm gonna forget what
it's called he called it lemon ball but
it's actually got a very specific name
it's where one of the ducks
testicular ducts uh so you had a
varicocele
yes or a hydrocele hydrogen fluid
hydrogen
is uh fluid around the around the testes
so your scrotum or
your sac on one side looks like you've
stuffed a party balloon
yeah so he had he had hydrocele but even
him
as a person i think at the time who was
third year
med school yeah maybe fourth year med
school even him
the the um inbuilt denial of medical
problems ran
so deep that even he was like no no no
it's always been that's that size always
one's always been a bit bigger than the
other it's fine and it just like
gone around and this is how people like
you say can almost accumulate
this little collection of things it's
like oh well one of them has got to the
point where i need to see you about that
and by the way here's all of the other
[ __ ] that i didn't want to bring up in
the interim
yeah absolutely and and that's the um
sort of in the introduction i talk a bit
about
windows and uh and the idea that um
as a gp you know i hold up this this
window pane and stare into your life
you know i see your house i see your you
know i'm looking at your life and
and there are different types of
patients so you get the patients who
come in and say
you know hold up the window and they
point at their knee and say max um you
know i've got knee pain
can i can you um can you look at it and
you get those who sort of hold up when
to go
and go max i'm i'm worried about my
cholesterol but then i say
you're worried about your cholesterol
but i've despied your your blood sugar
result and i'm worried about you
developing diabetes
so different agenda and then finally you
get
people who hold up the window to someone
else
and they go i'm worried about my loved
one and and they say
you know i'm worried often it's i'm
worried about my aging parent i think
they're getting a bit more confused i'm
worried they've got dementia
so it's not that they are it's not about
them it's about another person and
they're the challenging cases because
you're kind of you haven't you can't
talk necessarily talk to that
person who's come to see you about
somebody else you can't talk to their
about you can listen to them
you can listen to everything they had to
say
but you can't necessarily say here's
what i'm going to do
you can say okay i'm going to book to
have them come in and see them myself
but you can't you can't discuss someone
else's case um
if you know with a relative if they
haven't given permission
so yeah it's all about windows and
journeys it's interesting that uh
the process of someone who isn't the
patient coming in
on behalf of the patient i imagine that
must be there's a whole host of
different
tripwires for both parties to fall over
there yeah
absolutely and and it gets you know it
gets a bit muddy
when you kind of look at teenagers you
know when you start you know you phone
up
you see you've got a 15 year old patient
she's phoned up and she wants the oral
contraceptive pill
and you look at her phone details
and it's got a home phone number and
then a mobile number
and you've got no idea if that's mom's
mobile number dad's mobile number
the guardian's mobile number the nanny's
all the patients
and then you phone and you're like hello
it's dr skittle can i
can i speak to so-and-so and then
immediately like the next day you might
get a phone call from the mother
saying what did you talk to my daughter
about
and you have to say well i'm really
sorry but it's it's confidential
and yes she's under 16 but she has
something called gillig competence which
basically says
uh which is specific around um or
sort of uh sort of contraception so
young girls who want to have all
contraceptions called it's called
gillette competence gillig g-i-l-l-i-c-k
and there's also fraser confidence as
competence as well which is
sort of bigger picture um and
uh but it's basically saying if someone
is in a sexual relationship under the
age of 16 and uh it is
with someone of a similar age there's no
signs of abuse or
um grooming and they are going to have
sex anyway
you know you don't want to be the doctor
that says well fine i'm not going to
give you
um contraception because um you're under
16. what you say is well look
if if you are not going to stop having
sex i want to be
help you be as safe as you can be and
against unwanted pregnancies
um and of course at all counseling about
safe sex and condoms and stis is a whole
different issue
and but but if that patient if that
young woman has a
young girl has a the the capacity to
retain
understand and communicate the decision
that they would like to make
you have to respect that and you have to
respect their confidentiality and the
only time you would break it
is if you suddenly found that there were
um
you know signs of abuse or grooming or
anything that made you feel that this
was
a safeguarding issue but if the mother
calls you have very very difficult
conversations because you're
you essentially are you know your duties
to the patient um
and all you can do is encourage the the
patient to speak to her mother
um and and of course you do that you
know you don't just go
oh let's keep this secret between you
and i you say
she wants to talk about this with your
mother because it's a big issue and i
think that you know
it would be really helpful if she's
supportive and we get that you know i
get
um teenagers coming with their mum and
and saying i'd like to go on the
contraceptive pill and it might not be
for safe sex
for sort of protecting against them
unwanted pregnancies they might because
they're having really difficult
um problems with their menstrual cycle
um
which you know as a gp as a male gp
something i never thought i'd be so
comfortable talking about but
you know after all these years like it's
not
it's it's we see it every day we're
talking about everyone just a bit of
menstruation yeah yeah exactly i mean
that and
because that is normal i mean the the um
the worst most frustrating case i had
just to talk about menstruation for a
second chris
that's what we're here for was uh was i
had a a
teenager come in with her mom really
embarrassed and the school had actually
asked for
her to get a letter from the gp to
explain
why she was able to be excused from her
classes
um because of her heavy and painful
menstrual cycle
which infuriated me because you know
this is a
natural normal healthy physiological
process
for women um and and it
was 100 stigmatized by that school
in that moment and and embarrassed that
that child uh she was a child you know
she was sort of
14 years old and um embarrassed her for
the fact that she has to hand a letter
to her teachers
um so then i basically said well fine
here's a letter
but i'm going to extend my scope of
of that letter and say that and teachers
are not to be
asking her what she's leaving the
classroom for so far i know she knows
she can
she can go out whenever she wants now um
yeah because but the point and and also
the school can pick up the phone and
speak to me
if they want to talk about anything else
because just a
a child a 14 year old should not be made
to feel like that
and um and and just they're things that
i feel
just really strongly about like you have
to fight these people's corner because
people will say no that's normal you
need to save and actually no it's not
you shouldn't be stigmatizing something
that is a healthy process
um a normal physiological process in in
women
and making this young girl feel
uncomfortable um
and make her feel potentially more
uncomfortable about talking about it
with other professionals in the future
any harder
well this is um we spoke recently
on this show to do with the peak end
rule have you heard about this
no okay this might be interesting this
might be interesting for you as someone
who has to deal with a high volume of
patience and you you don't want to cause
problems
the pecan rule is a psychological bias
that suggests our memory applies a
higher weight
to the most intense and the end of any
experience
so let's say that you're going on a
roller coaster you will remember the
most scary bit
and the last bit and the original study
was conducted
during endoscopies and what they found
was that
they could actually extend the length of
time
that someone was undergoing the surgery
and bring their level of discomfort down
at the end
and the rate of perceived discomfort
retrospectively
ended up being significantly lower even
though by every objective measure
that actually left it in for longer than
it needed to be
um and i wonder when i was thinking
about that
there was this quote where they said one
of the most uh compassionate things that
you can do for a young child your young
child
that's going to a doctor's or a dentist
or whatever if they're going to have
something that's going to make them feel
uncomfortable is to do that is to almost
extend it and dampen down the discomfort
toward the end
because over time that compounding
effect that that girl now you could
hit the nail on the head could be
terrified of talking to anybody in
authority about
anything to do with her body for the
rest of life or you know
a three-year-old that needs to have a
complicated uh dentist
operation and it goes a bit it's kind of
a bit painful and whatever and that's it
rest of your life
terrified of the dentist big
implications here absolutely and and
because of that i think that you know
you strip the medicine out of it you
know being a gp
or being in healthcare in general you
have a huge responsibility because
every every patient contact you have
particularly with children
you are setting the tone you're you're
you're
you know you're setting a bar at which
their
experiences of seeing a doctor or a
healthcare professional
which is why when i see kids it is
as fun for me as it hopefully is for
them there are stickers we talk about
their favorite um toys or what sports
they like
um and and often they don't really even
realize that they're being examined or
that we've done a consultation
and and in the same measure
whenever someone comes with a parent
you talk to the you talk to the child
first
like it's you don't talk to the parent
and i and that's really really important
because they need to realize that
you are my focus um it's about you
so i'll be like mom and dad just sit
tight for a second i want to hear from
i want to hear from from little susie
um and then i'll chat to her and then at
the end i'll go
susie do you mind if i ask your mom and
dad some questions as well and
yeah more than that they'll say yeah
fine because
it has to be about them and then and
then they enjoy it and
one of the you know most rewarding thing
about
about my experiences working in the in a
city gp is that
um i'll get kids come back and want to
see me
or even it's a sister of a little boy
that i saw
but the little boy wanted to come with
the sister because they were coming back
to see me
and they wanted to have another sticker
such a trick dr skittle yeah that's
cool man which is which is really nice
and actually
you know whatever all the [ __ ] that
happened
it it's stuff like that this is really
heartwarming and just makes me love
love the job and i spoke to a patient
the other day
who was having a real change of life
direction had got through some
quite difficult mental health issues
and he was like just to say thanks like
you
totally changed my life and it's not
about changing people's lives and it's
it's uh it's not gonna do that but my
god it was really nice to hear that
actually you'd had that kind of an
impact
that's really lovely to hear i i tweeted
something similar the other day that
said
um if you love your favorite content
creators tell them that you enjoy their
content because a message means an awful
lot more
than a play count and it's the same for
you like just getting someone better
that is more than sufficient that's why
you say it over and over again in the
book you
do it for that reason as a caregiver but
someone coming back
to do that must really sort of drive
that nail home
it does it it really does and um and
that's
yeah i mean i love it i mean that's it's
you don't go looking for it
and you don't sort of go to i certainly
don't go to work every day expecting to
see it
um or hear it but when when it comes
along it's
it's lovely pretty special yeah what do
you wish
that dr skittle from five years ago
knew that you know now with regards to
work or if you've got some
some junior doctors perhaps ones that
are just about to graduate or ones that
are on locum and about to go into
what are what are some of the things
that that they should know or that you
wish union
well that's a tough question um
let me just think about that for a
second what would i would i want to
tell somebody just what are you um
that it gets that it gets
easier in many respects
that the the the sort of um
the conscious processes that you go
through as a doctor
get more automated and uh
when i see a patient now i don't think
right what is their presenting complaint
right what's their past medical history
right what's their drug history
right what's their social history it
just comes out in a conversation
and i think that's what i would say from
a professional perspective
from a personal perspective i would say
always look after your own well-being as
well
because you can burn out very easily as
a doctor if you
or a nurse or any healthcare
professional if you
um if you just don't eat don't drink
don't sleep don't look after yourself in
some way in some way
um um don't look after yourself in some
way because if you do that
you're then no good to the patient
you need you need to help to you know be
blunt being really blunt you need a
healthy gp
if you get you pick a per a burnt out
exhausted just emotionally shattered
shell of a man or a woman they are not
going to want to help you at 6
30 on a friday if you're the umpteenth
patient they've seen
and that is their that's their capacity
you need someone who um is
is just ready to keep going feels fresh
and that's that's why it's so
that's why it's important and also
partly i really feel like i should
explain this
why we don't work five days a week in
clinics
you know i don't i don't work monday to
friday
seeing patients every single day there's
one day where i do something differently
um and that's because emotionally you
can't handle that burden and you would
really burn out quite quickly
i found that so interesting the the sort
of parting insight that i'd love to get
from you
is how doctors deal with
the emotional distress and the trauma
associated with the job
because you get taught all of the things
that you need to do
but from again speaking to a ton of
buddies that have been through
med school it doesn't seem like there's
a massive amount of explanation on
how to deal with being able to save a
patient's life that you really cared
about or hearing a sad story about a
family member who doesn't want to come
in or any of that stuff what some of the
ways that you've
found are effective for for getting
through that
so so i mean for me i've always found
that
i've been able to manage um those things
quite well
but i think what really helps is
[Music]
the things that help all of us you know
it's exercising
it's trying to uh eat well
and talking to your friends about these
things or talking to your loved ones
um and just decompressing
writing a book i don't know you know
yeah
you've just got to find ways to get
through it and but people will deal with
it very differently
you know and general practice is an
interesting one because
you get you get characters in your gps
who are
incredibly soft and softly spoken to
very brash and brutish and and
everything in between and i think that
uh there's no big lessons
it's just about this knowing doing gap
you know we i think we're all
intelligent we all know what we should
be doing we all know what helps someone
de-stress and
and process um work stresses it doesn't
have to be just being general practice
or healthcare
you know um and it's about recognizing
what you
know you should be doing and actually
doing it um
i think sometimes that's the gap so for
example for me at the moment i know i
have an exercise for about
four weeks and i absolutely know that i
should be doing it but my god chris i
cannot drag myself out for that first
run
gyms are open soon don't worry max gyms
are open
we don't know how long so we've got
there's some really cool takeaways here
i love the idea of
turning up on time dressing
appropriately and and not not
letting everything build up hopefully
will have helped a bunch of doctors and
potential
med students as well i mean yeah i
didn't get around to this but another
tip would be
don't come in and show me a photo of
your [ __ ]
that would also be was it was it a photo
or a video
uh it was a photo a photo looked like a
sort of brown drawstring bag and i was
like well
you know what do you want me to do with
that yeah i need to see it get it
i need to see it i've actually had it's
been an interesting few weeks i've had
quite a few dick pics recently actually
from
from patients so okay um
[Music]
all clinically indicated um uh but you
know
it happens and you have and that's the
other probably
one of the golden takeaways is don't be
embarrassed
like i've seen it all right your your gp
has seen it all
like it's don't be shy about talking
about
problems with your uranus or a vagina
or a breast or what happens during sex
or
pain during sex like it could be a
symptom of something so just talk to us
about it and a good gp
will make you feel comfortable when you
do that and i think that's the real
litmus test
you know you have to feel comfortable as
a patient with who you are
speaking to and and that's something
that you know i work to every day
it's just an [ __ ] everyone's got one
that is the parting note
i've talked to the max
it's just an [ __ ] everyone's got one
um
usually i'd be hey man what do you want
to plug your people to find you but you
are actively
actively anonymous so all i can say is
the secret gp will be linked in the show
notes below go and check that out on
amazon
really cool read fans of adam kaye i've
also got
chris dawg qc from justice on trial
coming on very soon it sounds an awful
lot like he's the
he's going to do the uh litigative the
law
side version of this so that'll be uh
that'll be really interesting but man
thank you so much
love the book and um good luck getting
through the rest of coronavirus
thanks chris take care of you bye-bye
[Music]